rival gangs at war a common occurrence
on the Cape Flats where people say
they're terrorized by gangs dealing
drugs the video recorded by people
living in a block of flats the shots
rang out and they ran for cover this is
where two weeks ago three children and a
19 year old suspected gang member was
shot and killed at point-blank range
Imran macadam from the ALS's River
community policing forum shows us where
gunman entered a shack killing almost
everyone in it when they came in the
shorty angle teen years old in the face
crew simply executing amputee Niall you
know and the two moms in we shot it
randomly and they rolled of the bid and
one of them actually played did to help
ensure else's River is plagued by
violence much of it linked to gangs
selling drugs their fight for control
often escalates into gun battles leaving
communities in the firing line there was
no reason for them to kill the children
and it was clearly as a message of
vengeance to this whole community but
mostly to the rival gang that this is
what they capable of government
statistics say the number of murders on
the Cape Flats have almost doubled to 90
this year that's despite the army being
sent in the military says soldiers were
sent to the Cape Flats to create a safe
environment so police could do their job
but people who live here say they only
see soldiers on the streets a few times
a week often for just a few hours at a
time they say little has changed the
army deployment was meant to last three
months but has been extended to next
March soldiers patrol the streets man
checkpoints and gather intelligence I
think that the Minister of police put
the army in there as a political
response I don't think too much thought
went into that process if you bring the
army in you you militarize the situation
and you you u.s. continue there's a good
escalating violence Brazil is an example
of that
you you you have warlike people on the
police side and in the army son when the
army was sent in to support
overstretched police last month police
minister Beckett daily said the
deployment would be a temporary fix but
even with the army there the police
haven't been able to stop the killings
and peace remains elusive for many
living on the Cape Flats Femina mela al
jazeera cape town